right I think we'll start up with
Jennifer Raymond
all right good morning yesterday someone
asked me when is the cerebellum session
and this is it the next 30 minutes and I
may be the only one in the room who
works on the cerebellum but hopefully
some of the ideas that are coming out of
our work on cerebellum will be useful to
many of you in thinking about other
brain areas as well and I will echo at
least one of the themes you heard
yesterday in Jim Karen's talk on the
medial temporal lobe where we are also
I'll also be telling a story whereby
we're finding heterogeneity in what had
previously been considered kind of a
monolithic brain area and the
heterogeneity I'll talk about has to do
with the properties of synaptic
plasticity so my lab essentially is
interested in understanding the logic of
how neural circuits tune their own
performance through experience and that
logic is embedded in the rules that
individual synapses use to determine
whether they should change or stay the
same so an individual synapse doesn't
know what's happening in the world but
is making a local decision do I need to
change or stay the same based on the
pattern of activation it experiences so
my lab is interested in better
understanding those rules and then
ultimately how the rules at different
synapses within a circuit are
coordinated so that together they define
an effective way to tune that circuits
performance now of course we have some
ideas about the rules governing
plasticity at synapses from the work
that's been done over many years in
brain slices where we know for example
many synapses have hebbian plasticity
whereby cells that fire together tend to
wire together two cells are Co active
the synapse between them tends to get
stronger we also know about spike
timing-dependent plasticity whereby you
can get long term potentiation or
depression depending on whether the
presynaptic neuron fires before or after
the postsynaptic neuron and I think the
general assumption has been that there
are just a few generic forms of synaptic
plasticity of these types
are implemented at synapses throughout
the brain and the way that you get
specialization for a particular learning
task the assumption has been comes not
from the synaptic mechanisms but from
the way they're embedded in a particular
circuit architecture I have been my
assumption but what I'll show you today
is that the synaptic plasticity rules
themselves can be precisely tuned for a
particular behavioral task so that's
going to be the take-home message we
discovered this by working on plasticity
at the parallel fiber to Purkinje cell
synapses and almost exactly 50 years ago
David Marr and James Albus hypothesized
that long term depression an associative
form of long term depression at the
cerebellar parallel fiber to Purkinje
cells synapses is a key mechanism for
cerebellum dependent learning I think
there's some truth in this idea as I'll
say a bit more about in a minute so let
me take you through this kind of
textbook model of cerebellar learning
the Purkinje cells are the sole output
neurons of the cerebellar cortex so you
can think of them as representing all
the different responses that the
cerebellar cortex might want to make
there are two inputs to the cerebellum
one comes from mossy fibers via the
granule cells which make the parallel
fibers you can think of them as
representing all of the different
contexts in which you might want to make
a response so by modifying the
appropriate set of parallel fiber to
Purkinje cell synapses you can learn to
make the right response to a given
context the other part of this model has
to do with the other input to the
cerebellum which comes from the climbing
fibers they come out of the inferior
olive in the brain and the they seem to
carry
feedback about the quality of the
response and Maura had hypothesized that
this feedback was a reinforcing signal
that would strengthen synapses that led
to a good response all of us
hypothesized that this feedback was an
error signal that would weaken synapses
that led to a bad response and it was
all buses error correcting version of
this story that's best supported by the
physiology because if you record from
climbing fibers during a variety of
tasks
they seem to encode errors and in slices
climbing fiber activation can induce an
associative long term depression the
parallel fibers that are Co activated so
sometimes this is referred to as an anti
hebbian form of plasticity because the
associative form of plasticity is
depression and if you just activate the
parallel fibers alone you get
potentiation okay so this is the
textbook model of cerebellar and
learning whereby you get a gradual
sculpting away of synapses that lead to
errors through this associative form of
long term depression my lab studies this
form of Ltd and its role in learning in
the context of this behavior the
vestibulo-ocular reflex or vo are really
proud of my performance as the are at
one of our lab spin trips here up in
Tahoe so this is a reflexive eye
movement that tends to stabilize images
on the retina when the head turns this
movement is sensed by the vestibular
system which drives an eye movement in
the opposite direction so if the head
turns left the eyes turned right and
vice-versa
so this reflex keeps the eyes pointing
in the same direction as the head moves
about in the world and that improves
vision by stabilizing images on the
retina in order to do its job of
stabilizing images this reflex needs to
be well calibrated and that calibration
is implemented through cerebellum
dependent motor learning if for any
reason the V or fails to stabilize
images the cerebellar learning kicks in
and adjust the amplitude or the timing
of the eye movement responses until
images are against table during head
motion this kind of simple form of
learning Maps very nicely onto the more
albus model that I described in the
relevant part of the cerebellum which is
the floc ulis the parallel fibers encode
the vestibular signal that drives the
response the Purkinje cells if you
activate them electrically or
optogenetic lee can drive an eye
movement and the climbing fibers in this
part of the cerebellum encode what I'm
calling retinal flip image motion on the
retina
and the goal of this reflex is to
stabilize images on the retina so if
there's image motion during head turns
that means there's an error
the climbing fibers encode that error so
there's this nice mapping without Ito
first pointed this out in the 70s
nice mapping of the simple ocular motor
learning tasks onto the classic Marv
Albus model of cerebellar learning over
the years there's been a lot of debate
about is LPD the mechanism of cerebellar
learning or not work in my own lab
suggests that under particular
conditions this Ltd mechanism is
recruited during cerebellar learning and
slight changes in how you do the
training can cause Ltd to not get
recruited that's a different story but
we think that this is at least sometimes
recruited to support learning there's a
question yeah there's a three neuron
reflex arc through the brainstem so you
can lesion the cerebellum and you still
have a vor but in order to calibrate it
you need the cerebellum and in the
similar way if you lesion the cerebellum
people are not paralyzed but their
movements are not well calibrated again
so you know you would tune it up during
development but during change as the
muscles change their strength during
development or aging you'll need to
recalibrate again when you get a new
pair of glasses with slightly different
magnification you need to adjust the
gain of your VOR so the idea like any
movement we initially calibrate it but
we're constantly monitoring the accuracy
of our movements and adjusting it
through cerebellar learning so it's it's
an image motion signal it's coming
through largely subcortical visual
pathways nucleus of the optic tract but
that's another interesting question you
know we usually study this you know
learning under conditions where the
whole world moves in a way that we can
control but under normal conditions
things are moving in different
directions on the retina depending on
where things are relative to my focal
plane
and and so that's another whole
interesting question of under that
condition what image motion drives the
climbing fibers that we've looked at a
bit too but that's a different story
so the cerebellum knows about this the
cerebellum knows about the yeah so we
don't know yeah there is you can you do
adjust your view or for different depths
so you have a higher gain when you're
fixing something near versus far and
those need to be independently
calibrated that's not the main point of
what I'll talk about here but it is
exquisitely calibrated the amplitude and
timing of the eye movements are
exquisitely calibrated knowledge I will
show you that timing part of it yeah so
this is a question of you know do you
get learning every time the climbing
fiber fires and does the climbing fiber
fire every time there's an error and
I'll show you a little bit of that so
let me keep going here and okay so we
have evidence we had our lab has despite
controversy about does Ltd contributor
or not we had in our lab recording
stimulation and perturbation evidence
convergent evidence that at least under
a particular set of conditions that we
can define this mechanism got recruited
yet there was this thing that had always
bothered me ever since I was a postdoc
with Steve Lewis burger the thing that
had bothered me is how do you use a
coincidence based associative plasticity
mechanism to support learning in the
face of feedback delays so this is a
problem not just here it's a problem for
any kind of feedback based learning how
to use coincidence based synaptic
mechanisms to do that and here when I
was a postdoc we estimated that the
delay for the climbing fibers to respond
to an error is a hundred and twenty-two
milliseconds we got that specific number
fitting fitting but the phase shifts
that we got across different frequencies
with a constant delay we then fit
mouse data from another lab that was
monkeys mice we got 121 and mice so
there's a pretty consistent delay at
least under high contrast visual
conditions for the climbing fibers to
respond a pretty long delay and the
question is how does the system deal
with that one possibility was suggested
by what had been described in the
synaptic literature which is that
there's a pretty broad coincidence
window had been reported for these
synapses for inducing Ltd and so a lot
of people had used coincident parallel
fiber and climbing fiber activation this
has worked from waivered Garrett's lab
at Harvard showing they could get the
Ltd when the climbing fiber was delayed
50 milliseconds or 150 milliseconds
relative to the parallel fiber and even
if the climbing fiber which supposedly
has the error was stimulated before the
parallel fibers they also got Ltd so
there's a window of a couple of hundred
milliseconds that might solve this delay
problem by being broad enough to
accommodate those long delays however
that never quite set right with me
because one of the things we know the
cerebellum does is very precise timing
and even a weekend athlete even you and
I can time our our movements with a
precision on the order of a few
milliseconds so if you're throwing a
ball the difference in timing between
the release and the arm movement if
you're 5 or 10 milliseconds too early
you will miss the target way too high
and if you're 5 or 10 milliseconds late
you will miss it way too low so you and
I can time our movements with a
precision on the order of 10
milliseconds imagine ways you might do
that with super resolution and this kind
of sloppy synaptic mechanism but I'll
show you that that doesn't seem to be
the case oh also we had evidence in vivo
that we can precisely time our eye
movements and this had come from doing a
trial by trial analysis of plasticity in
the intact circuit but modeled after
what Javier Medina had done with Steve
Louis Berger so Javier said and this
gets back to your question Peter
climbing fibers have a low firing rate
of about one Hertz
and even if there was an error every
trial a given climbing fiber will fire
on some trials and not fire on some
trials and so Xavier hypothesized that
if the climbing fiber is what's driving
the plasticity in this circuit then
every time the climbing fiber fires we
should be able to detect the induction
of a little bit of plasticity and on
trials where it doesn't fire we would
not see anything if it's the driver of
the plasticity and so on and the way he
did this analysis in the way we did is
by using single recordings from Purkinje
cells and you can record two kinds of
spikes in the Purkinje cell normal
sodium spikes that are called simple
spikes they are coming out of the
Purkinje cells at 50 or 100 spikes per
second and then there are these complex
spikes in calcium spikes that are the
signature of a spike in the Purkinje
cells climbing fiber input so each
Purkinje cell gets input from a single
climbing fiber and each spike in the
climbing fiber produces one of these
characteristic complex spikes so with a
single recording we get two pieces of
information we see the error signals
coming in on the climbing fiber input
and we see what happens to the Purkinje
cell output so what Xavier and we did is
look for pairs of trials where there's a
spike in the climbing fiber on one trial
and we ask what happens to the Purkinje
cells output on the next trial and if
the climbing fiber is inducing a little
bit of depression in the excitatory
parallel fiber inputs maybe we'll see a
little bit of a decrease in the Purkinje
cells output on the next trial and much
to my surprise that's what they reported
in 2008 so here are their results
averaging together all the trials where
the climbing fiber fired and then
looking at the trial to trial change in
Purkinje cell output they saw that when
the climate fibre fired the Purkinje
cell fired less on the next trial if
there was no spike in the climbing fiber
there was no change so there was a very
tight correlation between the occurrence
of error signals on the Purkinje cells
climbing fiber input and the changes
that it underwent so we did the same
analysis but with one key difference and
that isn't how we aligned this analysis
oh and I should point out that in their
work they saw this kind of 200
millisecond window during which the
Purkinje cell decreased its firing
that's very reminiscent of what I showed
you in the synaptic data as well but we
redid the analysis and whereas they had
aligned their analysis on the time of
the trial start we a student in the lab
kind of pain we we redid this aligning
on the time that the climbing fiber
fired within the trial instead of on
trial start and then she asked what
happens to the Purkinje cells output at
that time in the next trial and when she
did this this amazing temporal precision
fell out so what she saw is there was a
decrease in for Kinji cell output on the
trial after a climbing fiber spike but
that decrease didn't happen
at the time when the climbing fiber
fired but at an earlier time about a
hundred hundred and fifty milliseconds
earlier so it looks like the climbing
fiber when it fires is not inducing
synaptic changes in the synapses active
around the time the climbing fiber
reports the error but that's the earlier
time when the error was getting
generated seeming to at least partially
solve what there is called the temporal
credit assignment problem we I'm one
trial the climbing fiber fires so if the
climbing fiber fired 200 milliseconds
into the trial and we ask what happens
to the Purkinje cell output we're
looking at the trial to trial change in
Purkinje cell output aligned on that
time so i'm one trial the climbing fiber
will fire at 200 milliseconds into the
trial another time it will fire 300
milliseconds in so we're lining on the
time of the climbing fiber spike and
we're saying what happens to the
Purkinje cell output relative to that
and so what I'm showing here is that
there's a little artifact at zero but
around the time the climbing fiber fired
we don't see any change in the Purkinje
cells output it seems to be inducing
plasti see in the synapses that were
active a hundred or 150 milliseconds
earlier and that's the time that the
error was generated
not the time that the error got reported
back in the car me fibre and we see it
not just in the Purkinje cells output
but we also see it in the eye velocity
which suggests that when the climbing
fibers fire there should be some pretty
good correlation across the whole
population we can talk about that okay
so that still left us with this
disconnect between this kind of broad
coincidence window that had been
described for the synaptic plasticity
and the kind of temporal precision on
the order of tens of milliseconds that
we needed to account for what we saw in
the intact circuit and the behavior so
just do you mind going back one hour
just trying to understand cuz it's some
level I mean it has to do with where
your confidence bounds are but you're
the curve looks like if you did this a
million times you might see that the
deviation actually is broader at least
there yeah the red one that there may be
a low there's a truth well I'm just
thinking like from negative 200 to
negative 100 right I mean I'm just
trying to figure out like what what
level of precision do you feel like is
actually there from that and what level
is sort of a statistical inference issue
well I'll show you this what we think is
the synaptic mechanism of this and it we
also haven't narrowed it down to the you
know is it five milliseconds or 10
milliseconds but it's it's very similar
so let me keep going so I can show you
the results and then we can talk about
them so a very talented postdoc in the
lab a partner super thon found I think
what is the resolution of this apparent
discrepancy between the synaptic
properties and what's needed to support
the behavior a partner just started her
own lab at McGill last month and she
what she found had to do with comparing
different parts of the cerebellum the
properties of plasticity at the parallel
fiber to Purkinje cell synapses I'll
show you differ in different parts of
the cerebellum previously almost
everything we knew about the synaptic
physiology of the cerebellum had come
from the vermis which is on the midline
because it's easy to slice and keep
everything in the plane as you like
Aparna made slices of the flock ulis
which is the part that supports the
oculomotor learning tasks we study in my
lab and when she did that she found the
properties of synaptic plasticity were
quite different
so first she made slices of the vermin
she did the experiment everybody does
300 coincident activations of parallel
fibers and climbing fibers she got Ltd
like everyone else has reported and then
she did the same experiment making
slices with the flock ulis and instead
of Ltd she got LTP and I mentioned LTP
is the non associated form of plasticity
at these synapses it's what you see if
you just stimulate the parallel fibers
so it's as if the slice didn't even see
the climbing fiber activation so the
first lesson for us was that there's
regional variation in the plasticity
rules even for the same anatomically
well-defined type of synapse the
cerebellum is described as crystalline
in its architecture the same five types
of neurons repeated in the same circular
architecture over and over throughout
the whole structure about what we found
was that the functional synaptic
properties differed in a dramatic way
between regions so let me let me show
you the data and then I'll talk about
that so so we thought about this 122
millisecond delay that the circuit would
normally see between parallel fiber
activation and the feedback on the
climbing fibers in vivo and when she
stimulated the slice using that delay
for the climbing fiber then she got a
beautiful long term depression so she
could get Ltd when she used the right
delay the behaviorally relevant delay
thanks is a summary of that so
coincident activation unlike what had
been reported in the vermis gave us LTP
if we delay the climbing fiber 120
milliseconds we got Ltd thanks to the
proverbial reviewer number three we
repeated this in a number of small
variations on this we measured the
changes in current clamp or voltage
clamp we used a single parallel fiber
stimulus or a little train it didn't
matter we got the same same same answer
no matter how we did it
coincident activation potentiation
hundred millisecond delay depression
tuning for that delay was quite precise
this gets back
Loren's question if we used a hundred
millisecond delay for the climbing
fibers we got significant potentiation
if we used 150 we got nothing
significant on average so we really only
see depression it with that behaviorally
relevant delay that the error signals
would normally take in vivo this form of
Ltd that we found is unlike any synaptic
mechanism that we know of that in other
synapses it's similar to stdp and that
there's a window of a few tens of
milliseconds that's effective for
inducing the associative plasticity but
unlike the stdp at most synapse is where
that window is closed to coincident in
this case it's shifted by more than 100
milliseconds from coincident and then
just to compare with what had been
described in the vermis and not just by
waver gars lab but other labs as well
there'd been this frog window described
to put these on the same time scale you
can see that what we see in the flock
ulis is an order of magnitude more
temporally precise okay but we had a
hard time believing that the flocculants
ice and the vermis was not precise
because as I said we think of the
cerebellum in general as doing temporal
precision so we went back to the vermis
and we were able to find precision there
as well we did this by using a form of
short-term plasticity so we did a single
pairing of parallel fiber and climbing
fiber activation and asked how that
changed the the parallel fiber to
Purkinje cell synapse analogous to that
trial to trial single trial analysis I
showed you in vivo and when a partner
did these experiments in the flock ulis
she saw the same tuning for a hundred
and twenty milliseconds for the
short-term depression that she had seen
for the long-term depression when she
went to the vermis she found she could
get the depression with coincident
activation if she delayed the climbing
fiber 100 milliseconds or 120 or 150
it was associative if she didn't
stimulate the climbing fiber she didn't
get it we had other controls where she
didn't stimulate the parallel fibers so
it required conjunctive activation of
parallel fiber and climbing fiber but it
seemed to have this broad coincidence
window like what happened to
scribed for Ltd however if she then
looked at individual cells she found
that the cells that showed the most
depression 4-0 showed very little at the
other intervals because now she's doing
short-term depression she can test each
cell on all of the different pairing
intervals the ones that like zero didn't
like the other intervals the ones that
like 200 didn't like the other intervals
and so on so although if you just
average them all together it looks like
there's not a temporal specificity but
this seems to be coming from averaging
together different cells that are tuned
for tightly tuned for different
intervals rather than a lack of tuning
in the cells and so to quantify this we
used a selectivity index if you so
that's just how much depression you get
at the best interval versus the others
if you do this on the population means
it doesn't look the firmest doesn't look
selected whoops
although the flock ulis does but if you
do it on individual cells then the
individual cells are almost equally non
significantly different from the flock
ulis in terms of how tightly tuned they
are so now getting to your question
Peter about function we were able to
find you know so the the punch line is
different parallel fiber to Purkinje
cell synapses are tuned for different
delays we were able to discover this by
working on the flock ulis where all of
the cells are contributing to eye
movements all of the climbing fibers
carry visual signals with a common delay
even though we restricted in the vermis
our experiments to to lobules there's a
lot of functional heterogeneity in those
lobules
and we know that those two parts of the
vermis some of the climbing fibers are
coming from the spinal cord carrying
somatosensory information at very short
Layton sees tens of milliseconds but
these lobules also light up in imaging
tasks for cognitive tasks where the
latencies would presumably be longer so
what we think is that there's different
cells are looking for different
intervals and we would hypothesize that
that map's on to the functionally
relevant delay for the error signals
coming into each cell
so you're saying but then one Purkinje
cell you don't have heterogeneous
synapses that like different delays
that's a prediction that's Tesla yeah
yeah because each cell gets input from
one climbing fiber and the delay between
that Purkinje cells activity and the
feedback coming in on its climbing fiber
input should determine the preferred
interval for all of its announces a cell
over to expect a delay to be different
or you expect it in in a region to have
a regional delight yeah we looked for
mapping within the vermis and couldn't
pull it out by comparing across slices
but that's something to go back to look
for more clustering on a finer scale
with a better technique so let me just
summarize the same story that you heard
from Jim that there you know the
cerebellum has been described as
crystalline and it's architecture but
within that crystal and architecture
there seems to be important functional
heterogeneity that matters we shouldn't
think of these brain areas like Sur
bellum and basal ganglia and hippocampus
as monolithic but actually having a
particular architecture on which is
layered important heterogeneity and then
the by looking at the flock ulis we were
able to see that that heterogeneity
reflects a tuning a functional tuning
for specific task demands so I'll stop
there and I saw Dan had his hand up
[Applause]
yeah so the long-term depression at
these synapses is postsynaptic and I'm
pretty sure we looked for a change in
paired pulse ratio with the short-term
depression and did not see it so this
observation this is the finding of the
tuning I think raises many interesting
questions how do you generated a
cellular level but this question that
you're asking is our favorite that we're
working on right now did this just arise
the revolution and then the right
circuits learn to take advantage of that
heterogeneity or is it actually tuned by
the statistics of delays that it sees
and we're testing that by perturbing the
normal delays and we might have the
answer yet but it's gonna be interesting
either way it's gonna be interesting
this is sort of a follow up just so I'm
struck by this we talked a little bit
yesterday about results like from
hippocampus where there's not like a new
second window where you can potentiate
things that are at least a few seconds
in the past which really suggests that
there's a whole new toolbox of things
that people could use to learn almost
any temporal relationship they want to
and I'm just like you know this is
suggest things like synaptic tagging and
weird biochemical time courses so I just
curious do you have any guesses or is
there anything out there that makes you
think okay this is sort of the kinds of
mechanisms we'd expect to see that would
support it you know you wanted to so how
do you build or do that yeah at first I
thought the hard thing is how do you get
such a narrow window at such a long
delay but as I thought about it more all
you need is something analogous to the
action potential where you have
something that builds up to a threshold
that opens the window for plasticity and
also triggers its clothes
and so then the question becomes how do
you build up to that threshold with such
a consistent time course and with a
different time course in different
Purkinje cells and so that's still a
hard problem and every cellular
physiologist I talk to has a different
pet idea you know
Serena's doodad works on calcium pumps
so she thinks it's a counseling pump so
it's gonna take an unbiased approach to
try to get to that I think because there
are too many candidates
yeah so there's a whole interesting
theory about why half of the neurons in
the mammalian brain are granule cells
cerebellar granule cells and the
interest one of the most interesting
ideas is that it's so that you can do
context specific learning so that you
can use the context of frames on my face
to have cue a different vor gain than in
the different context and context
specific learning is the kind of thing
you need for motor precision picture you
know opportunity so listen to this beam
of parallel fiber axons and so either
you know one time delay to this whole
Purkinje cell which has a hundred
thousand inputs it suggests that they
all have to have the same kind of you
know the error that they might be or we
all have to kind of agree on this delay
but then it kind of throws out the
window the the idea that that these
Purkinje cells integrating tons and tons
of inputs that might come from many many
different places which have a different
responsibility for the delay yeah so the
delay that matters is not like you know
they're getting auditory inputs that are
fast and visual inputs are slow but the
delay that matters is synapses that made
the Purkinje cell fire at this time and
the time it takes for that Purkinje set
whatever made it fire at this time led
to an eye movement that then maybe
caused retinal slip and that gets
reported back on the climbing fibers so
it's the time between the Purkinje
firing or you know the synapse is making
the Purkinje cell fire and the
evaluation of whether that was a good
outcome or not so the time it takes for
the parallel fibers to get activated is
not relevant it's the time from Purkinje
so getting activated by the synapses to
the feedback coming back
[Applause]